[Musique]
vous pensez quoi de l'arrivée des
trottinettes à toulouse mais j'aime pas
parce que après les gens savaient pas
conduit les à trottinette et aussi sa
rencontre des pollutions pour
l'électricité
je viens de séville en espagne en
utilise beaucoup le vélo mais dans le
centre-ville là trottinent et c'est
maintenant un peu nouveau aussi comme
dans l'eure et
ça et vos soeurs ils en pensent quoi
encore vos soeurs elles en pensent quoi
on veut faire la malle ashton
et bah là mais on est las ketchup et
m
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la
pollution à toulouse écoutez je pense
pas que toulouse soit aussi peuplé que
ça aussi pollué que ça maintenant il
faut demander tout ce qui habite toute
l'année ici
moi je viens ici pour mon plaisir une
fois par semaine à peu près et vous
habitez ou à la base
j'habite dans un petit village du lot
qui s'appelle montcuq et vos frères ils
habitent là-bas aussi
j'ai pas de frère oui tout à fait on
habite la bastille en effet oui on a
grandi à montcuq coiffé ou je tiens à
dire à tous les gens qui s'amusent à
dire montcuq c'est pas très drôle c'est
montcuq mexique
tout le monde est bienvenu à montcuq non
plus mon équipe alors excusez-moi what
is your opinion de position in toulouse
[Musique]
what about your sister's sister sister
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on se dit on et dire aux missions aussi
mais qu'est ce que vous pensez de la
pollution à toulouse la pollution à
toulouse on la sent beaucoup surtout
dans l'air vous venez de béziers ou une
différence avec béziers je vois une
différence avec béziers parce que bsa
reste une ville qui est pas très saine
en plus qui reste eau polluée mais
toulouse comme ça reste beaucoup plus
grand et qu'il ya beaucoup plus de monde
je trouve que c'est quand même une ville
qui est plus pollué et elle en pense
quoi vos soeurs mes soeurs alors elles
sont plutôt d'accord avec moi alors ça
on est 100 % d'accord de harcèlement
d'accord à 100%
elle a raison sur toute la ligne ça je
peux vous dire que on est d'accord à
100% même si on sait pas ce qu'elle a
dit qu'est ce que vous pensez de la
pollution à toulouse on la sent mais on
la sent c'est tout mais on on ressent
quand même que c'est pas forcément un
air très sain air frais propres
contrairement ici se fait pourtant si on
est vraiment à 200 mètres d'une d'une
avenue une avenue automobile mais ici on
sent déjà quand même un peu mieux au
final
bon il ya des endroits où on ne
ressemble plus à d'autres moins et
qu'est ce qu'on veut c'est de l'arrivée
des trottinettes à toulouse
sincèrement pour les trottinettes bas
écologiquement parlant
je sais pas trop ces bons selectric
forcément à la consommation électrique
la fabrication tout ça mais c'est plus
je pense au niveau des utilisateurs ou
ya quand même un problème et il en pense
quoi votre frère moi je suis tout à fait
d'accord quoi les trottinettes c'est
d'un jeu on peut foncer sur les gens
c'est quasiment une énorme en une arme
mortelle quoi je pense que tous nos
frères sont d'accord on est tous très
haut niveau merci c'est mon fond de la
chine
quels conseils vous auriez à donner aux
gens pour améliorer la qualité de l'air
à toulouse de l'air alors là je ne sais
pas moins en moins de voitures
je trouve qu'il ya beaucoup de transport
en commun envoyé on a pris les
transports en commun pour aller me
rappelle plus comment ça s'appelle
laurent c'est ça le revoilà et donc je
trouve qu'il y en a beaucoup à y aller a
les bus si elle
le tram ya le métro et ils ont pensé
quoi vos frères vos frères vos frères en
pense quoi
j'ai pas peur des balles on est d'accord
à la casquette 1
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]